foreign
we see a bunch of stuff about clones
forges and Darth bescar and even with
all that the most surprising thing is
that before he died the writers had
passed call this big hole they're
splitting the ceiling there you deserved
better rest in peace sweet prince use
the capital
coins we can't keep them in the air we
have to beat them on the ground after
paz's overestimation of the number of
Imperial troops in the last episode I
don't trust Mandalorian math anymore
seems like X always equals martyr
everyone and everything
you know I would have saved the
Imperials from having to deal with all
of this if they just killed Manda when
they had him dead rights in the previous
episode but instead they chose to take
him to the debriefing room alive for
reasons
also grogu was with the other
mandalorians during their escape in the
last episode did they just Blues him and
not bring it up or show concern in any
way whatsoever how dare you let our
precious grow go out of your sight
not giving us a functional reason why
these Thai interceptors have to be
stored in a way that requires the pilot
to do an immediate 90 degree turn upon
takeoff sir the fighters and bombers
have launched the Mandalorian chooses to
have a character relay that the fighters
and bombers have launched even though we
the audience just saw the fighters in
bombers launch this is information we
already have and we can believe that
Gideon was told this it's annoying
enough the show is cramming this final
battle the whole season's been building
up to into 35 minutes but yet we still
have to waste some of that time with the
previously on segment and now [__]
like this why Mandalorian why
let's talk about these helmets they have
no locking ring to connect the suit but
they still make some kind of
pressurization sound when people put
them on is it suctioning to their faces
is it applying moisturizer why is sound
number five
come in R5 last we saw our five made a
hard left getting off the gauntlet when
they first arrived I thought maybe they
went to take a piss and then got back on
the ship but now we see the Mando just
had R5 roaming the baron Wasteland of
Mandalore all on their own just so
there'd be a super convenient Droid to
provide maps and unlock doors in the
such and somehow that worked you're
gonna have to scomp into the base I just
had to look up scomp and I still don't
know what it is or means so this is a
sin for my poor research skills seems
only fair these Droids always sticking
their phallic metallics and unfamiliar
Yannick electronics and I'm fairly
certain they never have consent
got it good job buddy oh hey Mando what
happened to I'm sorry I don't speak
binary I don't speak it either but it
really felt like you understood exactly
what was being said there these shots of
the Mandos flying from the cruiser to
the gauntlets are as Andre 3000 might
say ice cold
how did the Imperial ships not run into
the mandalorians drop ships they
literally went down and came out of the
same cloud
avoiding all your guns Skyward when
you're being attacked from below there's
some barrier Shields I'm gonna need you
to deactivate them one at a time but why
are there all these barrier Shields I
get from a visual perspective it's fun
to have each one lifting and the Mando
fights off a couple security guards
behind each one and collects weapons
like it's a video game but it also seems
highly unnecessary if non-practical why
not just have one Shield at the end of
the corridor that's all you need also
are the Troopers not able to hear
through the shields because they should
be able to and should have already heard
Mando issue his orders to R5
what took these guys so long to react
man has been fighting their co-workers
for a good 30 seconds in this shot R5
does not have his third appendage down
but in the next shot it does R5 really
needs to have better control of his
appendages it's gonna get him into
trouble one of these days
Mando requests the next Shield before he
is properly dispatched to this gentleman
to create tension surrounding R5's
interaction with the repair Droid he's
yelling at R5 to open the shield as if
his life depends on it but in actuality
he has to deal with this Trooper first
before he's even ready to move on to the
next set two of these Droids are so
flabbergasted that they just drive right
off the edge were we supposed to feel
something about that sadness humor
bloodlust let's knock it in those are
his clones which is great because
there's nothing Star Wars fans love more
than an attack of the Clones
it's funny how clones always know when
you're staring at them in their tanks
got the sixth sense for when it's a good
time to do a jump scare but on the other
end of that is an equally terrified
clone whose first side in this life was
grogu in his Robo suit so here are two
sins for two jump scares Mando does a
bunch of button mashing and the tanks
just explode why is the water explosive
and how is that even an option we've
taken refuge in these surface cave since
the purge now I want to Purge movie set
in a galaxy far far away and I'm sad
because I know that will never happen I
want my Purge Wars they can blame the
Empire but I think these [__] that
can't go five minutes without using a
jet pack are the ones responsible for
scorching all the plant life on
Mandalore this inverted infantry charges
all of the cool but the mandalorians
advancing really seems like a threat
easily handled by a couple of tie
interceptors and we just so happened to
see two of those bad boys just hanging
around right here I know they're the
tools of a trade but armorer and Hammer
here should know that tongs are not the
right tool for every single job unless
they're Sonic in nature but that's a sin
for a different time I was isolating the
potential to wield the force writers
sure are dancing around just saying
midichlorians
oh goody we've got two badass looking
best car suited individuals who could
have all kinds of fun weapons but we're
just getting some Punchy Punchy stuff
that's fun also it's amazing how content
everyone is with punching people in a
helmet it doesn't make sense in football
and it doesn't make sense here now
growing punches those would be much more
effective in both scenarios good thing
they only sent three praetorian guards
anymore would have really [__] up this
entrance no oh no the wild thing here is
that grogu uses the no button instead of
the force and they still decide to not
run Mando through before giving Chase or
they saw a baby in a robot and decided
that was the bigger threat which I agree
with actually
koska's slide move is cool but how does
this result in her not being positioned
below the platform and out of line of
sight with her pursuers the guard's
inability to defeat a child even a
force-capable child undermines the
threat they pose making this almost
comedic while at the same time
undermining how hard pass fought against
them before he lost growfu is an awful
lot like yodafu seriously is this
episode trying to rectify attack of the
Clones because I assure you Star Wars
that can't be done I've got this go save
your kiss Beau has been nowhere near
this fight but somehow knows grogu is in
trouble these set pieces were nice
enough to respond proportionally to the
need for grogu to get trapped under
something
Amanda is now holding the business end
of the same weapon that went through Paz
and nothing we see or hear in this
episode is going to explain how this is
possible
except for that whole wait until the
last second to use the force thing but
otherwise good job hand over the dark
saber and I'll give you a Warrior's
death why would she do that why would
you ask that
episode kills the cool
stuff mandalorians are weak they lose
their trinkets I mean except for the
best car armor in the elite fighting
skills but yeah weak I guess
[Music]
sorry I have to ask this once again but
why the force is enforcing grogu using
the forcing Force the whole forcing time
this is a bigger fire but is it a hotter
fire because it should have spent a lot
of time showing people in armor not
getting burned by fire and if this is
all just a setup moth's eventual return
I'll send it again when that happens in
the words of the Creed shall be forever
forged in my heart are the words with
arms wide open I hope the words are With
Arms Wide Open you are now
yeah that didn't make the name any
better might have actually made it worse
didn't grogu sounds like the least
popular Ramen flavor at the local noodle
place
[Music]
the Mandalorian 2 the way of water
bocatan will now light the Olympic flame
and everyone will chant as if victory
has been won defeating a common enemy
will only get you so far eventually your
differences will creep back in and ax
will get upset at a board game again
for Mandalore
very nice that they brought ig-11 back
even though most of if not all of the
important parts have been replaced at
this point he's essentially the Droid of
Theseus and I'm not sure if he's enough
boat to protect Navarro from an army of
pirates din grogu is a din dick to frogs
also this ending is so Forest Gump that
I'm surprised the Frog didn't float away
on the Wind
you even know how to use this thing will
you cut me loose my dad needs my help
I'm gonna need you to be brave for me
okay I'd rather not
surprise [__]
RoboCop who is he what is he where does
he come from I thought this was gonna be
a street fight
goddamn right it is mandalorians are
weak once they lose their trinkets if
you want me to wear 37 pieces of flare
like you're a pretty boy over there
Brian why don't you just make the
minimum 37 pieces of flair
[Music]